Iran has launched more than a dozen
ballistic missiles at joint u.s. Iraqi
facilities in Iraq at least two bases
have been targeted one of them is in
Erbil and also the an al Asad Air Base
in Anbar province also Iran's
Revolutionary Guard has issued a warning
to Israel and other US allies in the
region saying they will be attacked if
their countries are used for strikes
against Tehran now in the last twenty or
so minutes we've had reaction from the
US president on Twitter of course and he
starts by saying all is well missiles
launched from Iran at two military bases
located in Iraq assessment of casualties
and damages taking place now so far so
good we have the most powerful most
well-equipped military anywhere in the
world by far I will be making a
statement tomorrow morning and then
we've also heard from iran's Foreign
Minister Mohammad Javad Zarif this is
what he said he said this before Donald
Trump I should point out as well Iran
took and concluded proportionate
measures in self-defense under Article
51 of the United Nations Charter
targeting a base from which cowardly
armed attack against our citizens and
senior officials were launched we do not
seek escalation or war but we'll defend
ourselves against any aggression so
that's the reaction we've had from two
of the biggest players we would say
another development we've got is that
the US Federal Aviation Authority the
FAA has now banned US airlines from
flying over airspace in Iraq also in
Iran in the Gulf of Oman a bit further
south and the waters between Iran and
Saudi Arabia in other words the Gulf
itself it is citing quote the potential
for miscalculation or misidentification
this is how the region's airspace looked
at Oh 100 hours GMT that was two hours
ago and we'll be keeping an eye on how
the skies are looking that is a ban for
US carriers but we'll see what knock-on
effect
they will be right let's start in
Baghdad Osama bin Javaid as I said 6:00
in the morning there and quite an
extraordinary night it's been take us
through it welcome all the sound of
helicopters in the air has now been just
replaced by the morning prayers here in
Baghdad as it's just over 6 a.m. we
mentioned people in Iraq will be waking
up to the news of this attack which
happened in Iraqi soil the worst fear
which was stated by Iraqi government
officials their country is yet again the
theater of war for two giants as
Iranians decided to attack two bases in
Iraq one in northern parts of Erbil and
the other one in Anbar province I had
the I in al-assad base in the last few
minutes we've heard from the Kurdish
Prime Minister I'm the Kurdish
semi-autonomous region saying that he
spoken to secretary Pompeo and suggested
steps for de-escalation as well as you
know that the second attack hit the
Kurdish semi-autonomous region in
northern Iraq the Kurdish p.m. and Sewer
Barzani insist tweeted he's among the
leaders who've now given their version
of events as you you cited there
president Donald Trump as well as the
Iraq the Iranian Foreign Minister we're
still waiting to hear from the Iraqi
government which inconspicuously remains
absent from the scene we've been
speaking to Iraqi officials all night
both government and political but we
haven't heard from the Iraqi leadership
itself with the last time we heard from
the Iraqi Prime Minister he said that
the only solution and the way forward is
for foreign troops to leave his country
and that's something that he's
reiterated in phone calls with world
leaders as well as the US ambassador
when he met him but as it stands more
than a dozen missiles landed at inal
acid base so far according to the US
president all as well and we have not
heard of any casualties
although there have been some
indications by some Iraqi security
officials that there might be some
injuries on the Iraqi security side that
again is coming from just one source one
Iraqi security official fearing that
there are some casualties but no further
details on that
as well so this is where we stand
according to the semi government agency
Tasneem in Iran some forces of the
popular mobilization forces also
launched their attack but that has not
been confirmed by either PMF sources on
the ground or any in their indication
apart from these missiles we have no
other reports of any other ground attack
being launched against any of these
bases so Islamic just - sorry I'm gonna
jump in there jump in there my friend
just to go back to the point you made
about not hearing from the Iraqi
government so far don't to state the
obvious here but this is all happening
in Iraq it is their country being used
as a battleground between the United
States and Iran at the moment and they
have a right to feel aggrieved about
that well I'm quite sure that they will
be once they decide to comment on this
and it is it's it's been a very eventful
night Kemal before in the lead up to
these attacks you heard from the
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and you
heard from the Secretary of Defense
Marquez / both of them directly
contradicting what the Iraqi Prime
Minister has been telling his people
Marquez / saying that the letter does
not an unsigned letter in his words does
not a signal a change in policy the
Iraqi p.m. a few hours ago said that the
last communication that he's had with
the coalition was that letter in fact
and Mike Pompeo came on on the podium
and and laughed about Qasem Soleimani
being indicated as somebody who was
carrying a message something directly
that the iraqi prime minister had told
his Parliament that Mike that Qasem
Soleimani was going to meet him in a few
hours before he was assassinated
so again iraq find itself in a very
difficult spot where the prime minister
is directly been contradicted by both
Secretary of Defense and state and the
iraqi prime minister had been warning
that there are concerns that iraq will
be dragged into this war it does not
want to be dragged into this war and
that was the concern on the ground on
the streets of Baghdad when we were
speaking to people they were concerned
they were afraid they fear the
repercussions of what could happen
as more and more steps are taken one MP
said to us that what happens when one
Americans death caused the death of an
Iranian general what if Iran attacks and
more Americans are killed where does it
stop and that is the kind of concern
that you we see on the streets here in
Iraq and I'm quite sure that many Iraqis
will wake up to this news as their worst
nightmare that they were expecting of
the repercussions after Qasem Soleimani
Anibal Marielle Mohandas were
assassinated just one thing I'd like you
to clarify for me a sum and that is the
basis which have been hit are these
Iraqi bases are these joint facilities
are these places where US troops happen
to be stationed just just just for
clarification well come on there are no
US bases per se in Iraq all of the
facilities that the us-led coalition is
using are in fact Iraqi bases that I
Nellis at base goes back to the 1970s it
was established by even before Saddam
Hussein and it was taken in the us-led
invasion in 20 2003 it was handed back
to the Iraqi security forces in 2011 and
in 2014 when the US forces started their
operation against ISIL they they
refurbished that base and we've been to
that base a multiple multiple times and
we've seen the kind of operations the
reconnaissance operations which happened
from analyst ed the kind of drones which
are flown their ground assets which are
there it's it's a sprawling complex and
probably holds more than a few hundred
troops at any given time an Erbil again
the facilities that they have are
jointly shared with the Kurdish
Peshmerga and the other base that they
have is with adjacent to the airport at
the Erbil International Airport so
besides the consulate and the embassy
that those are sovereign US territories
on Iraqi land every other base is a
Joint Base with one or the other one or
under the Iraqi security apparatus
excellent good to clear that up we'll
talk to you again soon Osama bin Javaid
in Baghdad just to remind you of the
team there's Osama on the left outside
beggars in Tehran as well we've got
Harry faucet in West Jerusalem talking
to the
all shortly but starting now with
Kimberly how could at the white house
where it is 10 past 10:00 in the evening
Kimberly did I hear you correctly saying
before that while the president is
tweeting the press Secretary's office
has gone dark
yes that is exactly what you heard me
say quite perplexing that at such a
heightened moment not only did we see
the lights go out in the press office
our main source of information here at
the White House but we saw the vice
president
leave no he doesn't live here at the
campus so it's not unusual for him to
leave in the evening but given the
tensions and what we're talking about it
was somewhat surprising given we know
that he was here as well as the
Secretary of State the Defense Secretary
even the chair of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff at one point in the Situation Room
alongside the president as we were
hearing the news and the reports of
these two strikes on the bases there
where US personnel military personnel
inside Iraq are occupying so this was
somewhat perplexing because what we can
deduct from all of this is the only
person communicating what's happening
right now is the president who's sitting
in the residence behind me tweeting
because he did tweet that all is well we
don't know what that means that we now
have to wait until the morning so given
the fact that it's 10 past 10 local time
here at least eight hours one would
suspect until the president in fact will
be talking to us now i Kemal I will tell
you that I have lost our IFB connection
so I'll just finish up with a couple of
thoughts if you are still hearing me but
the president's really backed himself
into a corner essentially he had earlier
in the day had some very tough talk with
the Minister prime minister of Greece
alongside him in the Oval Office saying
that if Iran took any action that the
United States would respond that there
would be some sort of response that
would be a very proportional if you will
but we haven't seen any evidence of that
or had any reports of that so and we're
left kind of wondering what this all
means and again this is something that
we'll have to wait now
suspect some number of hours until we
hear from the US president when he says
he will make an address to tell us
what's going on in the morning Kimberly
how could doing a great job there at the
White House we'll be back with her when
we connect again later on
moving on to Tehran now here's a sad beg
Assad let's compare what as Kimberly was
saying Donald Trump tweeting all is well
almost a sort of nothing to see here
Bing and as she says we don't really
know what that means yet
by comparison mohammad javad zarif
stweet quite nuanced actually
referencing the UN what was that article
51 of the UN Charter that's right he's
as far as Iran is concerned this is a
retaliation and a defensive action and
javad zarif saying that we don't seek
war and that's exactly what the
Revolutionary Guard here have been
saying it's what politicians have been
saying as far as they're concerned this
is a reaction to a specific event and
that event was the assassination of
Qasem Soleimani
we understand that Iran has also
returned to the United Nations and the
Secretary General and they've said that
they are not seeking war and have warned
against any military adventurism against
Iran so that let's has gone to the
United Nations United Nations and the
secretary-general but we we knew that
this was happening we knew that this was
going to happen I mean because it was a
matter of when not if because the
population the people on the streets
were asking for revenge the politicians
were calling for revenge and even the
supreme leader Ayatollah Khamenei has
said that there would be a retaliation
that there would be revenge and that and
the authorities the political
establishment here were the immense
pressure from the public because Qasem
Soleimani was a high-profile figure he
was revered as a patriot and after the
days of mourning as he was being buried
Iran essentially has made a statement by
launching those two waves of attacks now
what we do understand is that we are
hearing from some of the IRGC the
Revolutionary Guard linked News eight
since that there are two kinds of
missiles fired one has a range of 500
kilometers and has a guiding system and
the other one is the qiam war is called
the key arm and he adds the range of 750
to 800 kilometers but Iran says that
don't want escalation but they have
wound regional countries that host US
bases that if is launched against Iran
using those bases Iran will retaliate
they've also said that they do not
differentiate between Israel and the
United States and Iran does have proxies
and militias and allies in the region
they have militias in Iraq they have the
Houthi rebels in Yemen they have they
have militias in Syria but also they
have Hezbollah in Lebanon if the United
States decides to retaliate and this
could escalate very very quickly I said
just a quick mention if you wouldn't
mind about and let's not forget where
all of this started the death of custom
soleimani we're seeing live pictures of
this is the final stage of the burial
because it's been a long process three
full days
[Music]
yes his body was bought first to avars
then the holy city of Makkah then the
funeral took place in Tehran hair on
Monday where hundreds of thousands of
people came came out onto the streets
the supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini
led the prayer and then he was taken to
the holy city of Qom and now his home
city of Carmel where he wanted to be
buried alongside those that died
fighting in the iran-iraq war now that
Berryman was postponed because yesterday
there was a stampede and there were
multiple casualties and the authorities
didn't want another incident because
that his home city has a population of
around eight hundred twenty thousand but
101 droves of thousands of people
converged on that city to say their
farewells so we understand that he's
currently being buried now and he was a
very popular figure or his assassination
has managed to unite the different
political factions here in Iran just
back in November there were widespread
anti-government protests now we have
popular support for the go
and political establishment here because
of this assassination there's been
images of Qasem Soleimani put up around
the country on billboards of a motorway
hangovers even if you go to an ATM I
want to read throw some money you will
see an image of customs of the money on
those screens we saw people carrying his
image but also chanting and asking for
revenge
intercom intercom the Farsi word for
revenge and that and the head of the
IRGC yesterday spoke to the crowds and
he said that there would be revenge and
it would be crushing and it would would
be something that the United States
remember but he is being buried now in
this final survey that was postponed
after that stampede yesterday